[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube fella man
yes yes I haven't made a video in a
while but I'm back with another video to
make you entertained no you're not
entertained if you guys have no
wondering what I've been doing I've been
talking to my patreon folks so if you
have to sign up for the patreon they
know what's up but I was doing a shoot
for the past couple of weeks or a few
weeks so I was a little busy doing that
but now I'm back
you know just creating content not
overthinking [ __ ] just to be a part of
your life you stupid sons of [ __ ]
everything's skimming was amazing and if
anybody made you feel like [ __ ] while I
was gone you bring them to Uncle David
so I could get my [ __ ] back in the
face and let them know and use a little
[ __ ] bullies a [ __ ] man look back
hand of the face you know saying but how
big are they are they bigger than me are
they stronger did they go to prison
because I you're on your own which
brings me up to the video topic today or
the video that was sent in Wow take a
look at this
[Music]
you know before even watching the video
if you notice in the beginning there was
a line that was said by the man with the
silkie a sperm to listen the moment you
said don't disrespect me like that with
your soft ass voice I don't even need to
understand that the man that you're
taunting is about 500 pounds on a good
day you idiot are you gonna say don't
disrespect me like that
with fear in your eyes [ __ ] I look into
the windows of your soul and your spirit
checked out I'm trying to figure out how
you got so confident then you looked in
a man that looked like he was built off
the back of a mountain and you wouldn't
put your tender soft hands in his face
what the [ __ ] did you think was gonna
happen
did you hear the slap oh my god this
[ __ ] won't be able to pay soup
for weeks is here's the problem with
this and this is what I see I see a
young man with this just for me hair
slicked back you watched a lot of movies
with herbs maybe you listen to a lot of
youtubers and said you know what don't
be a [ __ ] and back down well listen
here you dumb [ __ ] you only say that the
people you can beat up it's okay to back
down I back down all the time I've got a
lot of talk in me like if anything else
if somebody comes up to me and I know
they can [ __ ] me up
I'm bark real loud you don't know this
but you decide to threaten him with some
regular people [ __ ] you [ __ ] up don't
disrespect me like that no you say crazy
[ __ ]
go put your hands on me [ __ ] I
will suck your we tell you something
does always get scared over some gay
[ __ ] and I have no idea why it's like
it's better now [ __ ] who naked now get
me go so so so so I'm just kidding
what's up the other problem is you
thought by talking all that [ __ ] that he
was gonna respect you more you thought
that by talking loud this man was going
to run away you dumb [ __ ] were you
watching national Geographics he's not a
mountain-lion [ __ ] look at him
when he slapped you I saw one of your
ancestors come out to here like what the
[ __ ] what you doing man well you really
want to fool anybody man you were so
scared in that video and look at this
[ __ ] right here
he made you so much his [ __ ] he rested
his ball sack on your chest and it was
too heavy for you to lift up if he
wanted to he could have had his way with
you he literally could have made you his
second wife what are you like maybe 17
18 years old he made you look like a
child there are times in this world
where you should stand down that would
be one of them look at the back of his
neck the back of his neck has more roles
than a cinnamon bun if somebody got more
than four folds in the back of their
neck that just means that's just a bunch
of their anger that's stored that got
nowhere else to go well my friend make
better choices stop [ __ ] with people
that can kill you and you just might
live well everybody I'll see y'all next
time